Good day everyone. We're just going to
have a bit of a general clean up around
here on this chilly, wet autumn
day. Well, it's not, is it? It's quite
warm, actually. Blue skies, no rain.
It's still time to get some of the
plants cleaned up a bit, some of the
plants out cuz their crops have
finished, and some new ones in. So, what
are we going to do today? We're going to
clean up the mint. We're going to get
rid of our eggplant which is past it
used by date and replace it with
carrots. And the reason for that I shall
explain. Now mint goes a bit funny. This
is actually apple mint I think from
memory that I grew from seed. We're just
going to cut all the dead stuff
off. Doesn't need a new basket at some
point. You can tell if it's apple mint
by the smell.
Zapple mint. Going to take every dead
bit
off. And if you look
here, we've got some lovely new growth.
So, this should come good, ready for
next summer when we'll have some more
apple mint. But I will put it in a new
basket. These aren't very good.
they start to collapse and all the water
comes out. We got the same sort of issue
with our strawberries. So, we'll just
cut some of the dead stuff off
there. I'll cut some of this dead stuff
off,
too. Get around the other side later.
But we still got some living things on
there, but we need to just trim it back
for the cold weather.
There we go. Not looking healthy, but he
should come back. We pulled out our
eggplant from this bed here. As I
mentioned, there's something about
putting things in this eggplant bed.
Eggplant is quite a hungry feeder. So,
there's not going to be a lot of
nutrients in this in this bed. And it's
quite sandy. Not a lot of organic matter
either.
But guess what? That's great for
carrots. So, I'm going to nip out and
grab some more carrot seeds. We're going
to just make a little bit of carrots up
here. Probably just some fairly standard
ones or the rainbow ones if they've got
them. And hopefully couple months time
we'll have lots more fresh carrots. Got
a few up the back, but need more. This
one here I think I need to clean out as
well cuz I don't think there's anything
growing in it. Used to have cucumbers.
Still got the garlic chives, but that's
about it. Uh, so what I'm thinking is
I'll build that up just a fraction with
some piggy past and we'll put some
beetroot in that one. And I've got an
empty pot over here which I'm going to
put one of my new trees in. So hang
about and we'll see how we get that lot
done. So what I've got from Dy's nursery
um cuz I just wanted to try it. Is a
black pepper tree. Not quite sure how
big this is. There we go. Gets to 2 to 5
meters but by being in a pot we should
be able to keep it down to a couple of
meters. It's
self-pollinating. The reason I wanted to
try pepper is I used to spend a lot of
time in Sri Lanka working.
And the pepper they grow there is
absolutely superb. It is very different
to what we buy locally if you're just
buying the cheap peppercorns. And I want
to see if growing my own will be any
good. So, he's going to go over in that
pot. We're going to clean this fell out
except for our garlic chives. Might grab
some of the seeds though. So, we're
going to put some beetroot in there, not
carrots. And I've just got some fairly
generic beetroot. There's a Detroit from
Elden. Uh more Detroit from Happy Valley
Seeds. Globe beetroot. More elder
beetroot. So, we'll just put some in
there. We'll plant them fairly closely
together uh and get them out as we need
them. get some baby beets and let some
of the others uh grow to full size for
pickling. All right, let's get that one
cleaned up. So, this is my garlic chive,
and I'm just going to grab a few seeds,
which I'll probably just give away cuz I
don't use that many garlic chives, and
this one will be good for what we need.
I'm ashamed to waste
them. So, we just rub those
off. There's a stink bug.
Just blow the light seed casings
off. And here we
have more garlic chive seeds than we
will ever
need. Let's go and put them away. We'll
come back and clear out that
bed. Okay. Okay. So, we're going to pop
this out. Use that for my
cucumbers. Said never throw anything
away. We got our piggy past, which is
the wonderful stuff. Put a really good
whack of it in there. Like so.
We're going to dig that
through. That is going to give lots of
organic matter to our beach fruit. What
I'll also do, I'll get some earthworm
casting since I've got so many of
them. Maybe we'll get some earthworms
active in here, too.
a
bulletproof a bulletproof garlic chise.
Yeah, I'll just get a bit of earthworm
castings. I actually might put some of
this where the carrots are going as
well, just to get some earthworms in
there. So, that's
plenty. Eggshells and all kinds of
goodies in there. Lots of volunteer
plants. So, probably from tomatoes
and capsicum and things that have been
composted in
there. That won't do any
harm. All right, that's nicely mixed in.
And what we're going to do, as I said,
we're going to
over
so and we'll thin them out when we need
them. Have some baby beads.
I
like how old that one
is. We might not use it. Do some for the
Aldi Detroit be
I said definitely over
[Music]
sewing. All
right, just about to cover them
up. We'll give them a water
in there. Some of my baby
earthworms.
Okay, that done. Let's get over the back
and get our pepper tree
in. This had my star fruit in it. Seed
that I grew from
seed. And as you can
see, it didn't make it. Oh well, we'll
try again. Let's dig in there. See what
we've got. We need to mon it as
well. That's not looking too
bad. All
right, dig that
through. Lovely stuff. It's piggy
post. All right, nice deep hole for
him. Come on. That's good
boy. Don't want to disturb the roots too
much. So, we just pop him in.
We'll get some mulch and mulch it as
well. There we go. Need a bigger
steak. And another one. So, I'm going to
get something to tie him
up. All right. Need another one for over
there. Little bit of this nice soft
tie. Should hold him
there. That'll keep them
going. There we go. And we'll just let
them grow up there. Nip them off when
they get about six or seven feet
tall. 6 ft tall. They won't be able to
reach and try and turn it into a bit of
a bush. All right. It's clear up
here. All right. As we're tidying up a
little bit here, I'm not sure my
strawberries here have actually made it
through. So, I'm going to a little bit
of pe off in
these just over the
top. And that was a spearmint that
certainly didn't might come back next
year. We'll leave it and see. In the
meantime, I'm going to put some of my
various basil in here. Now, the basil,
even if we don't use it, will give a
really nice aroma around here and
attract some bees. So, generally just a
good thing to put
in. Right, I'm going to loosen that up a
bit. We'll pop
some cinnamon basil in here. Again,
using
my little bottom
press. Isn't that cute? I really like
those.
Pop a couple in
[Music]
here. Still hoping my strawberries will
come back in summer, but if they don't,
they
don't. One last thing I'll show
you. Bruce is no longer a growhouse at
the moment.
Bruce is full of mushrooms. So, I've got
up the top here, there's blue syggies in
buckets. It's my humidifier that I
bought. Down here, we've got some king
oyster that I'm not sure is going to
grow cuz that's from very old grain
spawn I got before Christmas, but I'm
giving it a bit of time. See if it does.
More blue veggies and leftovers just in
a small bag. So, this is the environment
I'm growing mushrooms in now. It has
heat mats there for when we need them,
but humidifier is the main thing. And
now that it's meant to be cooling down,
we might be able to grow mushrooms
again. Well, there we go. Just a little
bit of a cleanup, little bit of
planting, watering those beetroot seeds
in about ready for
carrots. water my pepper tree
in. So, what are you up to this autumn
if you're in the southern hemisphere?
What are you up to in spring if you're
not? Let me know in the comments. We got
lots more to do out here. Give you an
update later on. Enjoy life. I'll catch
you out here. Blue
skies. Nothing but blue
skies. Oh, I see.